c'est l'histoire d'un combat qui a duré
six ans une enquête menée non pas par
des enquêteurs mais par une victime
sophie rôle est devenue malgré elle une
spécialiste des accidents de poids
lourds en juillet 2014 son mari
chauffeur routier mort percuté par un
autre camion qui traverse l'autoroute à
l'origine de l'accident
un pneu éclaté le décès de mon mari
m'appartient c'est une histoire
personnelle
ça devrait rester de l'entrepris v et la
question va être est-ce qu'il y en
aurait d'autres ça a été le début du
début puisqu'on est sur la partie
immergée de l'iceberg
j'en ai bien peur voici les images de
l'accident 2014
ce que sophie relais découvrira plus
tard c'est que d'autres accidents
mortels ont bien eu lieu en france dans
les mêmes circonstances
les mêmes trajectoires folle avec
toujours les mêmes pneus des goodyear
marathon quand vous en trouvez 3
effectivement vous dites à peut-être que
mais il ya tellement de possibilités sur
les éclatements deux thématiques donc
que vous avez toujours cette réserve de
dire est-ce qu'on est dans un cas
strictement similaire en 2019
un expert indépendant détail le
mécanisme de l'accident de son mari et
met directement en cause le fabricant de
pneus l'expert est très claire on n'a
pas un expert qui va émettre des
hypothèses là une certitude c'est que le
pneu a été mal fabriqués qui comporte
des défauts qui le rend impropre
justement à sa commercialisation et donc
à sa mise en circulation
donc il faut véritablement que la
société puisse s'exprimer
l'équipementier américain rejette toute
responsabilité dans un communiqué ils
affirment les équipes techniques qui ont
examiné le pneu ont trouvé des signes
évidents de dommages par un pacte aucun
défaut de fabrication n'a été constatée
sur le pneu sophie relais a de son côté
établi un sidérant inventaire en six ans
soixante seize accidents faisant 56
morts la plupart du temps les pneus de
la marque goodyear sont impliqués on
s'aperçoit d'un cas unique en quelque
sorte
d'autres commencent à souvenirs parce
que on leur a livrée comme version une
fatalité et que la panda pneus ça peut
arriver à tout le monde désolé
passez votre chemin en quelque sorte non
on s'aperçoit qu'en fait c'est le même
marque
le même type de pneus on est dans la
même année soufi relais n'a pas de
certitudes
juste des doutes qui s'accumulent elle
souhaite aujourd'hui que la justice
ouvre le dossier